the new valorep map is finally here it's
the first underwater map ever released
into the game and it's easily one of the
coolest looking too but now that there
are eight maps riot has decided to
remove split from the map pool so let's
talk about it
since fracture came out in september of
last year we've all been waiting for
riot to give us something new and it's
not just because most of you think that
fracture is [ __ ] but it's been nine
whole months at this point the new map
is called pearl and it honestly looks
pretty dope it's the first map set at
night and the entirety of it is enclosed
in an underwater dome that gives off
pretty big atlantis vibes although
there's no gimmick to the map there are
a lot of cool spots scattered through it
there's a comic book shop a store for
your scuba gear and a football shop
which makes sense because the map is
based in portugal now like i already
said the map looks cool but how does it
actually play well luckily liz and i
were given the chance to play it
yesterday on stream
i'm in so much danger it's not even
funny
spike down a
you get you can't you can't jump over it
okay
my initial thoughts are that it looks
great there are a lot of small choke
points and retaking sights sometimes
feels difficult because there's so many
angles to clear hopefully this feels a
bit better as i play the map more though
i expect to see plenty of op battles in
the corridor near b-side and over on
a-site there's a million little rat
spots to hide in as for mid it feels
pretty claustrophobic trying to take mid
can sometimes feel difficult because
you're exposed to at least three
different angles at all times one thing
i do want to talk about is how pearl
will affect valorante's esports scene
having eight maps in the game will have
a massive impact on proplay right now we
have seven maps in the pool so in a best
of five situation both teams get to ban
a map pick two maps and then there's one
left over as the fifth and final decider
so it makes sense that riot needed to
remove a map from the active pool but
the problem is i think that they removed
the wrong one
for whatever reason they decided to
remove split now i know not everyone
enjoyed split and in the early days of
valor we all pretty much agreed that it
was a [ __ ] map but after all the changes
i honestly didn't mind it i would have
much rather lost bind instead riot
claims that they spoke to many people
including pros before making this
decision but i'm genuinely curious who
the [ __ ] they talk to because every pro
i've ever spoken to seems to hate bind
liz even made a donut me a few months
ago where she outlined all of the
reasons that the community hates this
godforsaken map so if you're wondering
what the whole fuss is about then make
sure to check out that video i asked a
proto yesterday about riot's decision to
remove split and here's what he had to
say i'll get behind the [ __ ] out of this
map
get it out i knew i liked you
split don't get me wrong split and rank
is
one of the least enjoyable maps just
because people
i don't know it's ranked and uh
in competitive it's one of my favorite
maps uh i think it's a really good map
for competitive so i was a little
sad to hear that they're taking that map
out first when you've got a map like
mine that no one likes and if someone
likes bind they
honestly might have something wrong with
them now although i would have loved to
never touch bind again riot did give us
some insight as to why they chose split
in particular yeah so in in this
particular swap you know if we we're
looking at just pearl versus split right
um they actually have a decent amount of
similarities okay cool the mid play is
somewhat similar it's kind of short
range um you know i guess
split
technically a mid oh yeah yeah yeah
but this has a similar kind of setup
where there's kind of these four entry
points to the space and it's a little
bit tight range
so yeah we felt like
this map again like compared to split
had the most in common
so summing the two out made a lot of
sense so i understand their reasoning
when they say it like that why have two
maps in the active map pool that play
similarly it just wouldn't make sense
since i've only played two matches on
pearl at the time of writing this i
still have to find out for myself if it
actually does feel similar but just to
give one quick tl dr for all of you
split will be gone from competitive and
unrated queues next week there will be a
pearl only queue for two weeks then on
july 12th it will be added to the
competitive pool as for the pro scene
pro will be available starting with lcq
events in august and split will be
removed from the map pool right after
that so we won't see it at champions all
i know right now is that a lot of the
community including myself just don't
get it riot hinted that they might make
changes to split before bringing it back
but i still think that bind needs the
most work
then there will be a two week long pearl
queue
split will be gone from the
competitive on rated q's next week split
will be gone from the competitive and
unrated [ __ ] then there will be a two
week long pearl only queue and on july
but just to give one quick tl dr for all
of you
what